wow hello everybody oh welcome welcome i it's well i'm sorry
i'm very i'm very nervous right now because i'm i'm
sponsored by neo vets oh my god hello everybody i am i'm so
I'm so nervous right now because I'm literally being
sponsored by like basically uh one of my childhood websites
and um it is an honor that uh Neopets uh chose me to to do
this so I'm super nervous there's not really a script going
you know how sponsor stream you there's like a a script
going in where you're like okay you gotta read these points
uh make sure you read this make sure you say this there's
really not much of that the uh what basically like what they
told me was that all right we want you to showcase uh the
new plot the void within and and then you could do whatever
you want and i was like sweet okay
I'm just also you know how like I like I said huge shout out
a huge thank you um to Neopets for reaching out and um they
reached out to me um you might have noticed a couple months
earlier they actually uh they sent me like a care package
and everything that was like Neopets really to celebrate
like their 20 to like in preparation for their 25th
anniversary and then later on they're like you know what we
want to sponsor you and i was like me oh my god it's also
i'm sorry dragoon 4938120 um i sort of let you start for two
months now so i'm i'm really sorry um but like uh i know you
don't die so
and if you get sad you'll just turn into a gray pet and then
gray pets equals like up so like it like um the sadder you
get the more value you have as a neopet so like it's okay if
you're starving um anyway anyway uh they reached out to me
to tell us if I could check out the void within with all of
you guys and for those who don't know what the void within
is is basically in the past uh they used to do these like
big plots and everything where it progresses the lore
neopets i remember following um following plot lines all the
way from the miradel uh line so like back then when the
discovery of brightville um that was like i think that for
me was like the earliest plot line like plot they've done
when i was on neopets all the way i think like i remember
all the way to the altador cup uh like not altador just like
the altador plot line um so Void Within has been the newest
plot that they've established, and it's a really big thing
because it's been a very, very, very long time since they've
done a plot for Neo Pets to progress the lore.
If you guys didn't know, Neo Pets lore is actually crazy.
It's not just like, like, there's romance.
There's actual people, Neo Pets die.
and in their stories it's it's crazy there's actual like
there's death there's romance there's the lost city of
atlantis but like in neopet's term is like morocco or
whatever and then there's latari island and everything
there's violence it's actually insane there's like but like
you don't really see that going it yeah they apparently been
teasing this lore this plot since last year So it's like a
lot goes into like the neopets lore for those who don't
know.
I used to fall along to it as a little bird.
So it's I'm really thankful for neopets for sponsoring me.
And like I'm going to they like, you know, they're like,
okay, you can do like 30 minutes max.
I was like, it's okay.
I'm definitely going to stream over time because not only do
I want to explore the plot of neopets, but I also want to go
through like nostalgia and like go.
through go through like my memories and everything and uh
just like re like enjoy neopets again um but it's like a
little time capsule it's actually crazy you might see like
this front page might look like very um you know like this
front page might look like oh this looks new i when i when i
got i was like what is this and then i like swapped to here
and i was like oh my god that's the page i And it's like the
news feature.
I saw the news feature.
I was like, oh my god, it's like 2010 all over again.
It's like, oh my god.
You're also dying right now, but it's okay.
It's like fake dying.
You're not actually dying, guys.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
It's like a time capsule.
There's like so many memories just like flooding back in.
Also, it was so funny.
when we were discussing about this like when my team was
discussing with neopets they were like i talked about this
before i talked about this in pre-chat it was so funny they
were like oh yeah like what's like um like like what are
your like demographics and then like we gave them a
demographic so like it was like i think like it was like 80
uh male fans and then like 20 female fans and then they were
like oh we're a little worried because um um neopets pets is
predominantly with like female like female fans and then I
was like do not worry whatever I like my dragoons will like
too do not worry
I was like no do not worry
they will love neopets I love neopets they will love neopets
also um so they gave me they gave me uh a link regarding so
uh if you do have a neopets account feel free to join the uh
150k neocash giveaway um if you have a neopets account that
referral link was just for me like they they didn't even
give me that referral link i made that for myself i was They
didn't even ask that of me.
I just want you guys to join Neopets.
I don't they didn't even ask me to like make you guys sign
up I just want you guys to sign up.
I put that there myself
So please please use my referral link because I also get
free stuff if you use my like I get I get like Link!
Anyway,
so I'm just really, really happy.
They also, I also would love for you guys to follow NeoPets
on their social media platforms.
So please check out the description box.
Please check out the description box and follow them on
their social media platforms.
They are currently doing a lot of stuff right now to, like,
I guess, like, revitalize, um, revitalize, uh, the Neopets
community.
Because, like, I don't know if you guys know this, like, the
history, the history of Neopets is actually so elaborate.
Like, like, not, like, the storyline of Neopets, but, like,
the history of, like, uh, the, the website, like, ownership
itself.
And, like, it actually i thought this was so interesting but
um they the the company that now owns neopets was bought by
a fan that used to play neopets when they were younger and
then they wanted to make neopets like just as good as it was
during like like in the past so they this guy like the the
this guy bought the neopets company um and it created its
own company just for neopets and i thought that was like so
passionate like because they were like um yes a fan like
reacquired the ip because they're like i had so many good
memories um playing neopets and like they were like i really
want to like you know bring back the same memories bring
back old fans bring in new fans and like enjoyed neopets
like I did when I was younger and I was like what the fuck I
was like oh my god that you know like the passion for that
to do that and like creating its own company to just just to
uh just to focus on like neopets as well um but yes for
those who don't know neopets started off as like a website
for like college students and then later on as it got bigger
and bigger obviously it geared towards more of like the
children demographics and then but like you know um adults
it like taught you taught me so much regarding like um
regarding like i don't know like the internet like neopets
taught me a lot about like internet stuff i i learned how to
role play from neopets oh my god oh my god i was like
looking through my old accounts and I actually, I'm sorry, I
know I should be like progressing like, but like I need to
go through like nostalgia with you guys.
But like, yes, it taught me like interest rates.
It taught, also thank you guys so much for the memberships
and the super chats.
It taught me, um, it taught me like, uh, the stock market.
It taught me about interest rates from
like role playing and then i was like looking through i was
looking through my old accounts because like i remember my
old account names and then i forgot i created like because
like it teaches you how to code it teaches you how to like
code and everything oh yeah it teaches you how to gamble too
because there were there were horse races i forgot there's
not horse races they were called snail races but like there
was like a snail race track where you have to gamble for
money.
It talked to you about restocking.
It taught you about like, like, um, what's it called?
Scalping.
You become, you can become a scalper in Neopets.
There's like an auction post and everything.
Um, but like, oh my gosh, I need to show you guys this
because like, I found my old accounts and I forgot.
I used to like websites and stuff because like on your pets
page you can create your own like website via Neil pets and
like learn how to code and everything and then like I was
looking through and I forgot I used to like I I found I I
found my old fan art of the alt my old oh my god I was there
for the very first Altador Cup and I found my old fan art.
I was like, I love this.
By the way, I was there.
I was an OG haunted woods.
I was on the OG haunted woods team.
I never left and we won first place.
We were the champions at the very first Altador Cup.
I was there.
I don't have my main account anymore because I told you guys
the story got hacked.
But I was there.
I was in.
For those who don't know what the Altador Cup was, it was
like basically like the Neopets Olympics.
And like I was there on Ground Zero.
I was the OG Haunted Woods team.
The very first champions.
And then so like I found this.
it for like the second year and I improved it so much like I
was like oh my god this was like year later for like the
second season and then I like redrew it and everything and I
was like holy shit I remember as a kid I was like oh my god
it proved so much I was like and then and I found Like all
my old art and everything.
I was like, there's like the robot Aisha's.
And then like the cookie sye bunnies and everything.
I found so much of my old art.
I was like, holy shit.
Oh, that was like, I told you guys I was obsessed.
I was obsessed with Neopets.
And then now I'm going to be obsessed with Neopets again.
um like neopets made me draw more in uh in in general and
like i like kickstarted uh so much like of my like passion
for certain things on the internet so i'm like really happy
uh i'm just really happy to be able to be sponsored by them
and to like do stuff with them um as also if you guys didn't
uh the intro the intro music if you guys could hear the uh
the intro music for uh the uh for the intro it was from the
darkest fairy i literally pulled up the darkest fairy
soundtrack because that that game um that game was like one
of my favorite games on the ps2
i was i was so obsessed with that game and i only i told
this story before but like i only stopped playing the
darkest fairy because um because it went to a stealth
mission and i was a very stupid child so that i didn't
understand it was supposed to be a stealth mission where
you're supposed to stealth back into the castle so i like
spent days trying to figure out how to progress and like
walk around because i didn't read much i just like went with
the flow of things and i didn't realize they wanted me to
stealth inside and then like because i couldn't um i
couldn't self finish the game.
I never progressed and that was like back in the time when
like internet forums like didn't really like exist for like
the darkest fairy.
So like um every like every time I went to like EB games
which is like the American version of GameStop um I would be
like is there a strategy guide for the darkest fairy like I
would I would ask me I I would ask you I did not use like
the internet to look for like how like tutorials I would
like go to EB games And then like up to the shop you'll be
like is there is there a strategy because like all I knew
was like strategy guides I was like is there a strategy
guide for the darkest fairy and then the shopkeeper would
like go behind and would look I don't know I don't know just
stand there behind because they didn't want to tell the
child that like that didn't exist I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure the shopkeepers who whenever I ask the shopkeepers um
like like whenever I ask the shopkeepers if like if there
was a strategy guy they knew in their heart it didn't exist
but they didn't want to tell me straight on so they would go
behind into the back rooms and then like you know pretend
I'm pretty sure they would pretend to look for it And then
they would come back and be like, oh, sorry.
We don't seem to have it.
I'll be like, okay.
And I'll do that like at least once a month for like a
couple of...
I don't even know how long I did it for it.
Because I really wanted to get past that stupid fucking
level.
Because I didn't realize you had the stealth.
I was just like, how do I do this?
Why do I keep getting caught?
But I would just be like, do you have the strategy guide for
the darkest fairy?
Oh my god.
Anyway, I'm super duper very excited.
I'm sorry, this was a long tangent, but like I'm very
passionate about, I'm really, really passionate about
Neopets because it really, really kickstarted my like, my...
It's like a curse, I guess it could be a little curse, but
like it literally kickstarted like my Um rabbit hole into
like the internet
So so I'm just really happy Um I'm really happy to be able
to like go through this with all of you guys Uh He's not
going to die My new pets doesn't die the more sad they are
the better better for my economy because it gives me a
potential where it will become a rare pet and after it
becomes a rare pet his value will go up so so it's all
strategic it's all you will become more beautiful the more
you starve the more value you have terry i don't know how to
actually A lot of these, like, Neopets names, I never really
learned how to pronounce their names.
And, like, in my head, I'll just call them, like, I don't
know.
I call them Pateri.
Because, like, I assume, like, because, like, there's a P
there.
So, like, I call them Pateri.
And then there's, like, Lupe.
And, oh, my favorite Neopets.
Someone was, like, asking me my favorite Neopets.
I wrote this down.
As Neopets asked me, the Neopets team, TNT, by the way.
That's when, you know, I'm OG.
tnt we call them the tnt uh because they're like uh the
neopets team um so like they actually asked me what my
favorite uh neopets were and i was like okay what was it i
was like i said like lupay lup okay here's like my uh here's
my top five lupay lutari uh sweet talk uh drakes and peteris
that is like the peterodactyl.
Oh, I see.
They're like, um, it's a reference to the peterodactyls.
Chias were fucking ugly.
Nobody can change my mind.
You know, okay, let me tell you the ugliest Neopets.
You know what?
I want to Chias.
Jub-Jubs.
the jump jumps were ugly okay the kikos
fight me I don't care they're ugly
how dare you um they're the worst because when you have the
secret okay so like in neopets there is like a map where
like you can grab like the secret lab map where you zap your
neopets and get like you can transform your neopets into
different species and different colors and then every time
every time like you know you there's a chance you get very
ugly neopet and like i i would be really you guys want to
know what the jump jumps are the jump jumps is this little
thing you see this oh wait you guys can't see it yet um wait
can you guys see it no i can't scroll it for enough.
Okay.
It's basically they have giant ass feet.
Please, I love chub chubs.
Chubs have giant ass feet and like no arms.
They're just a, they're just a ball of fur with like giant
feet.
So, and then, and then the Kikos, the Kikos was just a giant
head with like no feet with just arms.
So, like, I...
I just wasn't a fan.
I just wasn't a fan of them.
Um...
Anyway.
Um, anyway, sorry.
I forgot we were supposed to talk about the void within.
I'm so sorry.
This was like the main sponsor fight.
I'm sorry.
I just got really, really passionate.
Um, I got...
But like...
Um, so I'm just gonna go briefly over this because Because a
lot of, like, the newer Neopets players might not know,
like, might not know anything about this.
Like, because of the plot line, for those who don't know,
this is, like, the King of Altador.
I remember them.
The King of Altador, the King of Brightvale.
He's depressed.
Because the whole thing is that there's a curse right now.
There is a curse right now in the land of Neopia.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe I remember all this.
I can't.
It's been so many.
Many years since I've been on the offense and I can't
believe I like remember all of this Anyway I'm not making
this up I'm not making this up so like the only like So like
and so okay and then this is like the queen of the desert I
the was it the deserts um this is the king of the Moroccans
I think that's I don't know how to pronounce it these two
were like the king and queen of like the desert area.
I don't know who this girl is.
This must be a newer girl because I actually don't know who
this is.
But like, oh, they also have, they also have a parody of
Tomb Raider.
And it was like Hannah something.
They actually had like a parody of Tomb Raider too at one
point as like a plot for it.
And like, and she's a squirrel.
Yeah, it's Hannah.
Yeah, anyway.
Sorry, I got, I got, like, distracted.
But, um, I'm gonna go briefly over the void of it.
Um, because, like, a lot of the newer players, they're not
gonna really understand what is going on.
But the experienced players, you guys know what's up.
Yes, I'm, you guys better come back to Neopets because of
me.
Okay, if they ask you, like, why are you back at Neopets?
Just right, Doki Bird brought you back.
Okay, because, like, you know, I gotta, you know, I gotta
make Neopets know that, like, um, even though, like, you
know, like, let the Neopets know, like, we have a family.
base that loves neopets and doki introduced me reintroduce
slash introduce me to neopets again you know just like
potential for more in the future you know guys oh wouldn't
it be crazy if we did a collaboration merch line with
neopets wouldn't that be crazy guys um but they wouldn't
know unless we let them know that we have we have we have
the fan base um to guarantee that
oh my gosh anyway anyway no jub jubs though if we ever did
if we ever do a merch collaboration no jub jubs i'm sorry i
am a full-on jub jub hater
I'm willing to do any in-heel pets, but no jub-jubs.
Anyway, how could you hate...
Okay, guys, I'm gonna...
For the person that was like, how could you hate jub-jubs?
All right, for those who don't know what a jub-jub looks
like, I will...
There's a...
All right, let me...
Okay.
um oh my god i'm just looking at the job job i'm like uh i'm
just like all right give me a sec i'm saving the job job
right now this is why he's just look at him like like look
at him like like just what he's just feet
Cute, oh my god, no, he's just, he's just, okay, he's, look
at him, he's cute, he's cute, look at him, I'm not, yes, I'm
a full-on jump-jump hater, yes, that's what I've been
saying, I told you guys, can't change my mind, I'm find him
to be the ugliest neopet out there, out of all of them.
It's a, it's a fur beetle without nose.
They're very kickable.
Anyway, but yes, I like every neopet.
Okay, that's not true.
Um, I don't like every neopet because, like, Kikos are,
like, a good second.
Uh, a good second for me, like, of hate.
why does he look what does he look like a bald thank you the
super chat thank you thank you anyway so uh like i said they
so the reason he he's usually not depressed guys um i want
to okay akiko okay i'll show you guys what akiko looks like
kiko neopets uh i mean they're also equally okay so like
they're just they're just like They're like jub-jubs, but,
like, they have arms instead of feet.
And they look like, you could, like, like, pin from smiling
friends where you can pull, like, the hair.
Like, I know, like, this doesn't make sense, like, what I'm
saying right now.
But when you see the picture, you'll be like, oh, that's
what she means.
But, like, this is what a Kiko looks like.
This is a jub-jub.
And, like, you can combine them together, I guess, so you
can get...
Arms, I guess.
So, this is a Kiko and this is a Jub-Jub.
But, like, why would you have any of this when you can
clearly have the superior Neopet known as a Drake?
Like, why would you want any of these guys?
When you can, oh sorry, I'm trying to say, I know I'm trying
to save the picture of a Drake right now, like Give me a sec
It's a little difficult because I keep getting web MB
versions instead of PNG No, give me a fucking PNG Sorry,
like this is Sorry for the little like delay on this I'm
trying to get a, I'm trying to get PNG pictured But you'll
understand when you see it You'll understand and be like
Yeah, why the heck would I choose a or a uh kiko when i
could get this guy god where where's a png photo i'm sorry
i'm just trying to get a png guys all right give me a second
i'm snipping this i have to get my snipping tool out because
i'm desperate i need to show a drake why why would you pick
these two when you can get this guy on your team by the way
this guy is like super rare it's like two million dollars
but but you can tell why these guys these two are free this
guy is like two million dollars but
but there's there's you can tell you know these guys are
there's a reason why these two are free but this one costs
like money Oh, they're only 200k.
Oh, thank God for inflation.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, back in my day.
These guys were like 2 million neopoints, and they would
take forever to farm.
Because the only way, the only way you can get these guys,
the Drake, is you gotta either find a potion to morph your
neopets.
Or, or you gotta get like, uh, or you gotta hatch an egg.
And, and like, I only got it once because, um, one of my
friends, one of my friends quit Neopets, and then I begged
her to sell.
I, she got like, one of the, the Drake morphing potion.
She got, like, the mutant, the potion where you can morph
it.
to give me her neo to transfer her neo pets over to me
because because it was like my goal to oh it was like one of
my dream goals to own a a Drake like I it was the shittiest
name ever oh my gosh you would not understand in the neo pet
system in the in the we're not friends anymore by the way
But at least I got to It was like so long ago, it was like
So long ago, but I still got the drink Anyway, um Um It was
like one of my, one of my dream goals To own a drink Because
it was so difficult To own one, it was actually It had the
It had the like shittiest name ever Because it behind
Neopets There was a system where like You know um there was
like a there's like a trading uh there's like a trading uh
um community for neopets and like they like tier list your
neopets so like if you you need to have if you have like a
shitty name for your neopets as in you add numbers to it the
value of your neopets is lower like you can get your neopets
valued because you can't change the names of your neopets
but And some of them are like more well sought after than
others because there's like it's like well named There's
like well-named unconverted pets and unconverted pets are
usually pets on the old art style and That that shit was so
rare you can get them back now the unconverted pets are back
now But yeah if your neopets had numbers the value of your
neopets drop
Oh my god It was it was like an incredibly wild time back
then anyway Also another one of my favorite other favorite
neopets was Oh my gosh, I need to show you guys you guys
This is one of my other favorite neopets But like now that I
look back into it like people be like Alright, so these are
the ones that I hated but this one was like this is like a
fan favorite Like everybody loves this neopet, but it was
just a wolf But like it's a classic it's a cool-looking
wolf.
Okay, like it's just a dog the Lupe The Lupe is like my
number one favorite neopet But like you can't you can't mess
up the classics.
It's simple is good He's a dog I like dogs so so like I and
Lupe the Lupe's had like the best designs like the best roar
like the best paint brushes the best okay the unconverted
ones I'm I don't like the okay Lupe okay Lupe Royal brush so
like you can paint your pets and everything and okay I think
it was like the plush one was like one of my favorite it was
either the plushie lupé oh no the baby the baby lupé was so
cute okay that was like one of my goals anyway it's because
they literally had the best designs when it came to like um
paint brushes and you're like what what what is what is joki
talking about like but you can like you can pay lots and
lots of money and like make it a fucking baby and it was so
cute and i was like okay yeah the royal ones were also
really cute too so you could make it uh a bait like a puppy
and i was like oh my god the colors um the colors were so
cute and everything i heard the paintbrush economy finally
has has fallen so thank god like i'm so happy i'm so happy
inflation existed your pets oh thank god because um because
like saving up for these things where it was like all was so
hard to save up for especially when you're a child and you
didn't because like it was basically a monopoly for all the
adults so the adults usually had like were the richest
people in neopets because they actually knew how to min max
neopets so all the children were always sad and begging for
stuff because we were like the peasants in the kingdom of
adults and
i remember would be like we would be like please can anyone
can anyone please give me a paintbrush on poor
like we we were like freeloaders because we couldn't we
didn't really understand um and as i got older i started to
understand the ruthless the ruthless business of neopets so
i started to get rich and then i got so rich that actually i
i got hacked one day it was like i was so sad but like um
but it was just i was i think i was just really stupid
because i think i visited a bad website and then they took
my that was just there to like take neopets accounts it was
so long ago it was like my main account too but like um i
still love neopets though i still had like four other I
still had four other I still had like four other side
accounts that was filled with like secret labs and like
everything but you know when you lose your main account
that's like you know you lose a lot so um but it was still I
still love Neopets I still I still it was like what it is
like uh because back then oh my gosh I don't even Remember
this like OG Neo Pets players will remember this But there
was always people would be like don't get CG'd don't get
cookie grabbed That was always like the biggest scariest
thing back then we would be like don't get cookie grabbed
Don't get you lose your account if you get cookie grabs and
don't visit random websites They're gonna be here for your
Neo Pets account
It's like I know some of you guys were like what what are
these?
What are these terminologies?
It's an OG Neopets terminology.
Everybody was so paranoid.
We'll be like, oh my god, don't visit these websites.
They have cookie grabs there.
Yeah, not my cookies.
It was the Neopets boogeyman.
And all the little kids were so scared because they're like,
you can only visit Neopets sites because all these other
dangerous websites outside of Neopets, they're going to be
there for your Neopets account.
They're going to try and cookie grab you.
And we were all so scared.
We're going to be like, never visit the bad web.
Neopets is the only good website.
Never visit outside Neopets.
Anyway, sorry.
Sorry.
Off topic.
The void within.
So the reason why The king of Brightvale So for those for
those or sorry Miradel.
So there's this guy, right?
This guy he's usually not depressed, but like So there's
currently the curse The the gray curse right now and like
for those who don't know this is okay It's a little messed
up But like Gray pets Are highly valued I know Okay Because
we're like Oh my god The pets sad Money Stocks go up One of
my dream pets Was a gray drink Because it looked so pretty
But like he was sad Like Because they were cute Or like Oh
my god They were so cute I was Okay here I'll show you guys
They were No Trust me They were so cute They're like They're
like Depressed But like They were so cute Like It was a lot
of money To get one guys Like you don't understand They're
like highly valued Like
Here I'll show you guys So, this is, look!
It was so, it's so cute!
It's, it's so cute!
That's why you guys are starving.
Oh my, guys, this is why you're starving on my Neopets
account, because there's, like, a 1% chance.
There's a 1% chance that you'll turn into a gray, a gray pet
for free.
So, like, I'm taking that 1% chance.
Like, I'm taking that 1% chance.
For that to happen.
Mom, you don't get it.
I'm valuable in Neopets.
No, and, like, they're worth $6 million.
These guys are worth $6 million.
No, you guys don't understand.
Look at the Lupe.
The Gray Lupe.
Okay, never mind.
Gray Lupe is not as, like...
Okay, I will admit, I will admit, the gray looping might
look too depressing.
Like, I would admit that.
Okay, now that I'm looking back into it, the gray looping
might look a little bit too much.
Like, no, he was so cute.
Come on.
Like, he was incredibly cute.
Okay.
I, okay, but look at...
Okay, Deregan Lupe.
This is one of my most valuable pets I had.
Um, because, like, I thought that looked badass.
But this is, like, my most...
I'll show you guys my most valuable pet that I've ever
owned.
And he was, like, unconverted, too.
Oh, my God.
This is a big file.
Holy shit.
How big is this file?
Oh, my God.
this is a huge ass file what the fuck all the other files i
downloaded were like tiny as hell that shows how popular
this pet was this particular color was um but like this was
my most valuable pet a derogant lupe unconverted too by the
way because he he was like a badass dog it was um yes i had
an unconverted uh Derrigan Lupe, and that was why my account
got cookie grabbed because they wanted this guy.
They wanted this guy.
That was the main reason it got cookie grabbed.
Um, um, but this was my most valuable, uh, Nyope, um, that
I've ever owned.
And, anyway, sorry, off topic.
Sorry, we were supposed to talk about...
I can't help it.
I'm just going through, like, my memories and everything.
I, like, I played Neal Pets for years, guys.
I actually...
I played Neal Pets for years.
I did not have...
No, okay, the plushy pets were so cute, too.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no.
You can't say that.
You can't...
I did not have an emo phase.
plushy neopets were like so cute.
Like the Shoru plushy neopet was like one of the cutest that
they've ever had.
Alright, let me show you guys.
Okay, now you guys need to see why.
Like this was one of my dream neopets that I never owned
because I was a child and they were too expensive.
Children were...
Look at it!
He was so cute!
The plushy Shoru's?
Um...
it's because like back then um back then uh sorry i meant
whenever i said like dollars i meant neopoints by the way
but even then the neopoints currency was like so hard to
farm um but like um oh my god i do it there's so many things
like there was like a lot of goals i had within neopets
because you know i was a child and like back as a child you
know you don't have much other than school and so like you
like you had nothing to really strive for uh and doki what
about good grades anyway you had nothing to really strive
for as a child so in in in your pets i there was like i like
strive for particular goals within within new pets so so
that's stuff to do um i had stuff to do and like okay sorry
back to the plot the void within um anyway so that's why
he's sad because he doesn't look like that he looks like a
lot happier but there is a gray curse going on right now in
um in neopets to a point that it is turning it's turning a
lot of neopets around the uh neopian world gray so they're
all trying to figure it out and that is basically the plot
um they're always like really well crafted because it's like
um it's like a it's like a very elaborate arg within neopets
so neopets.com so if you guys enjoyed like arg and stuff um
it's very interesting because it affects everywhere uh
because it like everywhere you go like all different places
you visit uh um things start changing um and then you have
to follow uh you have to follow along and like uncover like
the mysteries and stuff um i remember being like i said i
was around since the mirror like since they discovered
miradel um and that was like the very first plot i was there
for uh but ah it's so um it's it's actually it's it's so
interesting like i love it when they i'm glad they're
bringing it back because this is something they haven't done
very very long time and um it's there their stories are
always like been i don't know as a kid i really enjoyed the
stories and i heard that this one like look at that this is
like the the timeline of like everything they've done
meredil grayed out as a rift appears so it's been like an
ongoing thing for like a year now um where like things are
like slowly changing um random events are happening And then
there's like the story here.
So you click this.
You get to interact with the story and everything.
So you can...
It's like this is a really classic thing that they've done.
So I've always loved Enilpet's style.
Like it's so iconic and everything.
So like you can see like they're telling the story and
everything.
You click next.
And you get to enjoy like what's happening.
So it's like basically like web tunes.
Neopets walked so web tunes can run
And then there's like a board For like to discuss about the
plot lines and everything And then you can send your Neopets
to battle Because I believe the void within Yeah web tuning
game
So you have to battle these Void Prowler.
I'm not going to send you to battle Because you guys might
Die so I don't have the money to heal you guys So I'm not
going to send you guys To battle because Oh I can volunteer
at the Neo Hospital Oh my god I could help you I could help
the others But you're like level one and I don't know if I
wanted to send you guys to battle Because I don't want to
Waste my money to heal you guys After so I'm
So I'm not gonna do it.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay, that was pretty funny.
I would, I would like go to the boards a lot back then.
um back then in uh neopets and this was the moment where i
had to send a permission form um i had to send a permission
form to like be allowed to talk on the boards because like i
said the boards were mainly for adults like yet to be over i
think like over 13 to be on the neopets board i was
like we're restricted to do stuff so we had to fax in a
permission sheet that was signed by my parents to the
neopets headquarters to be like she is old enough to like
talk to random strangers on the internet
she is she is we give her permission to talk to strangers on
the internet and so i was allowed to talk to people on the
internet.
Because, like, I didn't realize people can lie about their
age.
Because, like, back then, I was like, I don't know about
that.
Lying is wrong.
And so I actually, like, told the truth.
Oh, my God.
This is where I used to go.
Where is it?
Oh, there's stock.
Needs.
Wait, there's, wait, I don't remember this.
There's a stock to import.
Today I bought, wait, what?
Okay, wait a minute.
I didn't realize.
What does this mean?
Oh yeah, by the way, this is like, it's like remembering you
of like Gaia, Gaia online with like, can customize your you
know you can talk to other people on your best and then you
can like um i know i know the stock market i knew about it
but i didn't know there was an entire board dedicated to
this um and then um anyway so you can like customize like
your it's so funny you could like sold three to four 3k at
119 i just have a thousand stocks of They're selling.
Guess I'll sell them while they're high at 117.
Oh my god I feel like I'm reading the stock market for it
right now I told you guys Little Doki did not know what she
was doing.
Oh, I do.
I played the games to earn the money I just played the games
What the oh my god got is this?
What the heck is hyper stocking?
What are these terms?
Anyway, for those who want to not use, spend real money at
the stock market, but want to learn how to do the stock
market, I highly suggest if you're a stock market bro and
you want to learn or you want to get into learning, but not
invest in the real money on it, I highly suggest trying it
out on the Neo,
market um you guys want to know where it is okay i'll take
you guys there uh explore where is it it's here all right so
this is the map i'll show you guys uh post office should be
the stock market here okay neopian bank wait is the stock
market not here or is it in the bazaar it's been a long time
the chocolate oh my god this is so so many memories I tried
to do restocking, but I couldn't do restocking because my
internet was just not fast enough.
Also, if you're poor, you go to the soup kitchen here to
feed your pets.
If you're poor and you can't afford anything, you go to the
soup kitchen and then she'll feed your pets for free.
so you go here so you're like oh my god um i don't have
money please ma'am can you feed me because you're dying
right now so all i do is i click on this guy and then thanks
i needed that and then you're content now now you're just
very hungry and that's like all you deserve
oh my god where's the stock market they had the stock market
where is it how else am I gonna teach you guys the stock
market okay so guys where's the stock market guys also if
you're too rich they like won't let you in they know they
also know if you're too rich too uh it's in games you used
to be able to go to wait they move the location you used to
be able to like visit the town and like um visit the town
and like uh just go oh yeah but anyway here's the I'll show
you guys the bank the main shop let me take you to the main
shop and then um let's see I'm just okay I'll take you to
the bank um here you go so like this is where you learn
about interest rates so you basically you uh so right here
they're asking you to create an actual national neopian bank
so you have to create your own bank account and it like
teaches you what you need when your annual salary your
account type your initial deposit he's depressed i told you
it's the gray curse is going on and then you have to fill in
all these information but don't enter your real address
enter your neopian address um and uh just like i told you it
teaches you have what you need except for taxes um there's
no thank god there's no taxation here uh
i learned a lot i learned about coding and everything from
um from neopets oh it's okay it's in games okay we're gonna
find um i enjoy it's actually really fun you it's it's
really fun when you spent so much time um they also have all
the classic games are still like around and everything
because like a lot of the games that i used to play is still
there um where's the stock market i need to know where the
stock market is like that's the most important part okay all
games all games it's just start with is it just starts with
s uh oh my god they have okay which one was Oh god, I hated
the buzzer game.
I was so bad with the buzzer game Coconut shy was like my oh
the carnival terror good for farming And good for farming
money Normally the best farming neopoints games are the ones
that are Are the ones that are Are fast and like easy
because it only gives you a thousand it only gives you a
thousand neopoints points uh per play so like all I did
because I didn't really understand the stock market because
I was you know a child uh I I don't know but like I feel
like as a child you know you don't really I think like
trying to understand the stock market might be like a little
bit beyond my knowledge So, like, when I made money, I just
played the games.
I just like...
Oh, there he is.
There's stock market, bro.
There he is.
Okay.
This is how you invest in the stock market, guys.
So, buy, sell, buy, sell.
So every day, you can look at what...
I remember seeing this.
So I got, I once tried, I tried once at the stock market,
but like I did not understand.
So you look up here to understand what's going on every day
on the stock market.
And then you can find stocks here.
You search up specific or you go to the full list.
list of like what's going on um you see there's art ltd
there's um there's a lot of like very interesting companies
there's a bread oh my god the breadmaster bakery is still
around and then you can see the competitors of like how the
competitors are doing as well so like you can see the
competitors and then you go to like news and research to
read like um all right stock of the day today's stock of the
day is the cow cow farm
so if you guys don't want to like wait risk real money um
and want to learn how stock marking works um this is how you
do it this is how you do it Let's go back to exploring.
Oh my god.
Is everybody sad now in Miradel?
Because like, oh!
Oh my god, it's all gray!
The gray curse!
The value, their value went up.
Oh my god!
Their value went up!
Anyway, so like, I wonder what he looks like.
Is he sad?
Oh, oh, I don't, he's okay.
He's just, don't.
Hey, at least these guys are happy.
Wait, they're sad too?
Wait, no.
Okay, yeah.
Your word of wisdom.
If you'd make him think you're smart, you win stuff.
Anyway.
Wait, are they all sad?
It's just a little...
Only some of them are sad.
Okay, only some of them are sad.
Alright, that's good to know.
That's good to...
Okay.
Are you okay?
Grumpy old king?
Oh.
Okay, you guys want to know what he actually looks like?
Let me...
Alright, this is what he actually...
This is what he actually looks like, but the gray curse got
him.
Let me grab it for you guys.
This is like...
This is his real form.
Before it got him.
This is what he used to look like.
Now his value went up.
Oh my god, wait, why is he so cute?
I can fix him.
Oh my god.
He's grumpy.
Now he's sad.
Anyway, so this is what he looked like before the gray curse
came in.
So now he's sad.
Now he's a sad little guy.
Now, can he laugh?
Because, like, the thing is, what you do is that you tell
a...
You try to tell a joke to him.
And then, like, there's, like...
I wonder, what does he say?
What does he say if, like, I just tell him a random joke?
Like, will he laugh?
Will he cry?
he'll like cry or laugh but like not usually he'll be like
he'll laugh or like send you away if you're not funny oh i
got food that guess that wasn't too bad of a joke i probably
oh 600 what can you call upon a family of christmas arcade
akira's find a knack at advisor wesley at carrying her a bar
of the one fire 101 what are these words hey but He thought
it was 647 out of a thousand.
I did really good.
And he gave me free food.
You gotta chuckle.
I think the sadness is affecting his health, guys.
I think.
It's an A.
It's an AI.
It looked like a fucking chat GPD.
But guys.
I got it.
Guys, I got- I got sick.
I got free food.
I got peas.
Guys, I got peas.
It's okay.
Anyway, let's go back to explore.
Um, oh my god, Team Haunted Woods.
But there used to be like a lot of stuff.
You can- Oh my god.
This is- there's Altador right here.
There's- Oh, there's Shanku.
I remember Shanku when they- the world, um, is that- there's
Lutari Island.
Wait, can you actually go to Lutari Island now?
Are you- It's been yours.
Wait, what?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, oh my god.
The Lutari Island is part of the plot.
Oh my god.
Finally.
You can do something at Lutari Island.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's Jelly World.
I almost forgot about Jelly World.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy.
and finally you can do something in Littari Island um yeah
guys Jelly World oh yeah and then there's Rue Island there's
like Rue Island here whoa Rue Island like is like bigger now
it's like better uh there's Rue Island oh yeah you guys
cannot buy houses too by the way so if you guys didn't know
in um in neopets you can also do real estate uh you can you
can also own houses in neopets too and like um go into the
real estate business so um i bought a home in neopets as
well So, like, at least, you know, I own something, you
know?
Only in Neopets do I own a home.
I'm a real homeowner.
We learned marketing with me.
Anyway, where was I?
Oh, my God.
It's actually, like, there's so many memories just from...
Where is Jelly Island?
Wait, Moltera City?
Wait, that's new.
What's Moltera City?
What the...
What is this?
Is this like...
Steampunk?
Wait, I've never seen Motero City before.
Yeah, it's Steampunk.
That's so interesting.
Wait, this is actually so interesting.
This is new for me.
Oh!
Something happened!
Guys!
So like, this is what I mean by like random events.
Um...
This is what I mean by random events.
So like...
I'm waiting on the 1% chance that, like, I would get the
random event where, basically, you turn gray.
So, like, it's, like, a 1% chance where you encounter
somebody who's going to zap your pet into a gray pet.
And, like, that's what I'm waiting on right now.
That's what I'm waiting on.
Also, there's a...
The prices change every day because there's an inflation
rate.
So it lets you know what the inflation rate is.
Oh,
this quest line is broken.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is like the Matera, the Matera city.
All right, explore time.
Let's see.
Guys, oh my gosh, oh, I should open a shop.
Oh my god, I forgot.
Okay, wait, I need to grab an omelet.
Okay, it's in, it's not in the desert.
It's in, um, so we used to have dailies.
So you know in Genshin Impact, wait.
What the fuck?
What happened?
What happened to Terrania?
You guys are supposed to be stuck in the prehistoric age.
Who let you guys upgrade?
Who let you guys...
You were supposed to be forever stuck in the prehistoric
age.
Who let you upgrade?
Who taught you technology?
Technology Who gave you technology?
Anyway, anyway They advanced Who's that these guys advanced?
They're supposed to be Stone Age forever.
Anyway They learned how to read So But before I gotcha um in
the west before we had gotcha in the west we had neopets
dailies so every day we do dailies in neopets and one of
them is you can get free food by oh my god it's a sad omelet
now oh my god the curse the curse um anyway every day what
the what the fuck You grab some omelet and then you can grab
a slice.
But there's like links and stuff.
So every day there's like dailies to do.
What the?
Why do you guys...
You guys can build bridges now?
This is crazy.
Who taught you guys?
Oh yeah, and then we can gamble.
You click the wheel.
We spin the wheel to gamble.
So it costs 150 meal points.
And then we spin the wheel.
You can't really see it very well.
But you can spin the wheel!
You can get a paintbrush, too!
Look at that!
Wait, do I have to click it?
Do I have to click it?
Please do not create multiple counts to use the wheel as
unbalanced.
Your limit is spinning.
When does it end?
When does it...
Oh, I forgot it spins for four hours.
Oh, I fucked up.
I forgot.
I forgot, sorry.
This wheel spins for four hours.
So, um...
So, I guess I lost 150 neopoints.
I guess I...
I'll spin something else.
Okay, alright, so we have...
Don't worry, we have another wheel.
We have...
We have another wheel!
That we could spin.
The wheel of misfortune!
Spin that wheel!
That's another 150 points, but that's okay.
Yay!
What did I get?
Oh, shit.
Okay, you got neopox.
Don't worry, it's not fatal.
okay um um congratulations dragon you got you got neopugs
yay i could cure you but that that costs money so we're just
gonna explore we're just gonna explore instead like i could
heal you yes i could but i'm sorry i don't have i don't have
the funds right now guys i'm i'm poor guys oh yeah by the
way fairyland used to be is there still the invisible tower
where would the invisible tower be is it still here wait
where would the invisible tower be guys where's the
invisible tower oh Is this?
Is this the invisible tower?
I did it!
Okay I still got it.
Alright, so the invisible tower Is the tower is like a
secret hidden it was like a secret hidden tower Where you
can buy like really expensive.
There's a valentine paint brush now What?
Oh yeah, anyway, so like there's like Really rare brushes
really rare items here So like this is where you can buy
them it's not secret anymore because like um because it's
been out for like what neopets is 25 years old that's
actually insane to think about anyway i was as i was saying
i wanted to start a shop i'm gonna start shop all right you
don't have a shop it only costs how do i select create and
edit a shop okay i want to create a shop all right guys um
i'm gonna put it in the haunted woods i'm gonna call it um
let's see i'm gonna call it okay let me i need to know if
like anything pops up if i try typing let me double check
all right nice okay it doesn't all right nice all right
we're gonna call it what do you call okay oh okay doki merch
yes you're right doki merch all right buy my merch very
reasonable prices uh shopkeeper name okay uh joki uh
shopkeeper thank you for the uh akasupa thank you thank you
all right create shop oh okay select a new shopkeeper oh my
gosh okay they can run my shop for me guys i need to select
a new shopkeeper pets I don't want you guys to see who is
okay I'm gonna put oh yeah I need to get the peteri peteri
where are you peteri peteri oh okay yeah you guys can see it
all right which one which one should be me oh my god could
be a wizard I could be a wizard all right let's see shadow
oh that's gonna be me yeah that's gonna it be me all right
we run that as the shopkeeper update shop and then uh create
shop stock okay i want to add stuff into my shop my items
all right items okay nice i got the peas porridge and the
omelet all right so i clicked this i won't put in my shop
open up all right i could you guys but i'm gonna put it in
my shop all right and then i'm gonna put the peas too i'm
putting my peas in the shop as well put into your shop all
right nice okay and then if you stock i think that's good
it's rare okay 999 all right and then this one i'll put it
as 9 9 9 9 9 9 9 8 there you go nice also you can add a pin
number too if you want all right you guys don't see it you
guys don't see it guys it said it was rare guys look wait
did you guys buy it already did you did you guys buy did you
guys spend money already
wait wait a minute wait a minute where's the omelette what
the
easy as
fucking eat i'm rich i'm fucking rich i'm like you're rich
Okay, let's...
Let's fucking go!
Wait, what's the maximum that I can withdraw?
One, nine, nine, nine, nine, nine, six.
I grab all of it?
Yeah!
I Oh my god, you're grumpy now because you have kneelpox
You're so you used to be sad now you're sick and sad Wait,
wait, I need to look at you.
Oh my god All right Let's see I need to check I need to
check some stuff.
Oh, yeah, by the way, here's what I made for you guys You're
strong, but your defense is below happy, below average,
because we all know that we are not, we are not, uh, we are
not a defense, uh, person.
I'm not, no, we're too rich for the soup kitchen!
Chat, we're too rich for the soup kitchen now!
She's not gonna let us into the soup kitchen anymore!
Wait, what do I do if I go to find a cure?
Um...
Let's see.
What do I need to...
What do I need to do to cure you?
What is it?
Neopox?
Uh, watery eyes.
Neo...
Uh...
No, I'm poor!
Guys, the inflation!
Think about...
Where the...
Where the fuck is Neopox?
Neophobia?
Across...
This is us.
Yeah, it's...
guys this is this is us we need this um make them wear a
pair of step out shoes um where the fuck is there's
pneumonia there's no oh shit oh my god i don't i do not
remember pneumonia
i forgot some of the names oh there you go you have to feed
them if your pet it will be covered with Very itchy,
contagious red blotches.
Oh, you're just itchy?
You'll be fine.
You'll be fine, guys.
You're just itchy, guys.
You'll be...
You just got the cookies.
Guys, it's okay.
You're just...
You're just itchy.
Don't make me visit the pound.
Guys, what's the pound?
Don't worry.
I'll show you what the pound is.
Give me a second.
Let me...
I need to find the pound.
I need a donkey, please.
Give me a second.
I need to remember where the pound's located.
Oh, so we guys are like, what's the pound?
Don't worry, guys.
Let me find.
I need to find the pound real quick for you guys.
I need to find it.
The pound would treat us.
Guys, where's the pound?
Where's the neo pound?
located.
It's in the plaza?
Oh, somebody's been to the pound before.
Somebody has not a lot of knowledge about the pound, but
they remember it quite well.
All right.
So, um, Neopets, we have adopt, transfer, Or abandon.
So, when you go there...
Oh, shit, I got the doctor death.
You can basically...
They'll start, like, make me cry.
And then I can, like, pay 250 neopoints to throw you in the
pound.
But, yeah.
But then you can also adopt.
You know?
that's currently in transit oh wait does somebody try to
send me rare pets who try to send me stuff has offered what
the fuck no reject all right what the fuck why would i pay
you for that anyway um you can basically go there and like
adopt uh uh adopt neopets here so you can find thrown into
the pound and like usually people would like be really nice
and throw in like really really rare pets here and then uh
who keeps sending me pets if it's not a drink i don't want
it i want it i don't want it oh my god it's a it's a side
bunny oh my god Oh my god, you're in the Neal Lodge?
Oh my god, he's... She's at the hotel!
She's...
Shh, don't tell the dragoons, but you're my favorite.
There's no...
Oh wait, but it's like water snuggle.
I'm already replaced.
Guys, it's okay, guys.
Guys, I would never... You might be sick.
Oh, I can't even scroll down to see you anymore, guys.
I can't even...
I can't even scroll down to see you anymore.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
You're still my main.
Make act.
Don't worry, guys.
You're still my main, guys.
You're still my main Neopet.
At this point.
dude
what do you mean wait they were sending me a unique name I
did not know wait what unique name was it wait what was the
unique name I was not paying attention I was just like I was
just like oh I was just like oh I have one already I have a
dragon wait what was the name was it just it was my name oh
shit
Oh, oh, wait, wait, okay, I didn't notice.
Okay, okay, give me a sec.
All right, let's look at the transfer.
Let's look at the transfer.
All right, let's try this.
Oh, oh my God.
It's a drink.
Oh, it's a dream.
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're all so hungry, but it's okay if you turn into
a...
All right, anyway, sorry.
I got I'm sorry this I got distracted I don't
okay sorry wait wait okay um the one who has the dokey bird
the one that has the dokey bird um painted
painted I want I want a good value dokey bird
Now you're making demands.
Alright.
Okay.
Is there another transfer?
Oh!
Oh, that's my new favorite.
My new favorite.
I'm done playing with you.
I'm done at playing with you.
I'm gonna send you to the pal now.
No.
We're playing so fast.
All right.
The maximum pets you can have is four, by the way.
Holy shit, it's 20.
years old oh my god oh my god it has a pet pet it has a pet
pet click here to visit i love destruction my tiny giant
squid oh i have a pet pet oh it's five now no this is so bad
i only have okay guys i can only accept one more i'm sorry i
got way out of topic but i can only accept one more guys
there.
This don't keep bird.
What is that?
Wait, what?
No, I have to be so particular now.
Wait, what is that?
I can have six?
You can buy slots?
Wait, how do you buy slots?
Wait.
What is that?
I can't send don't keep bird to her.
I can have 11?
Oh, I need real money.
Okay, never mind.
I need real.
I need, sorry.
That requires real money.
I don't, I am, I'm sorry.
I, I'm going.
Okay.
Um, I'm sorry.
I have to reject.
I need to get Doki Bird in here.
I need to get Doki Bird.
in here.
I'm sorry.
I have to reject.
I already got two drakes.
I need a reject.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
It's your turn.
Oh my god.
No.
Do I want Doki bird or do I just want Doki Drake?
Okay,
guys, okay, do I want Doki bread or do I want Doki's right?
I'm sorry.
What will you do?
Do you know?
Exactly what I'm going to do.
You know exactly what I'm going to do.
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
Oh my god, just so fast.
You're literally just bored Okay, okay, I'm so sorry It was
so hard Wait, you can't send it because I rejected it?
No, you can't send it.
We can't still accept it?
Or is that?
Is that it?
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh, you need 24 hours.
In 24 hours.
We'll do it again.
We'll do this.
I'm sorry.
I just saw the yellow bit.
I was like, oh, I have one already.
Why would I get...
I didn't realize.
the name was Toki.
I didn't read.
You guys know I don't read.
You guys didn't know.
I didn't know.
I don't read at all.
Oh my god.
That's such really crazy.
I can't believe I rejected myself.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Toki not reading again.
Um.
But yeah.
Uh.
oh my god i just have like uh i i me and my me and my neopet
doki drake
wait is plastic really good is that is that really rare
brush what's wrong with plastic what's what what is up with
plastic doki drake says sigh wait His name was plastic?
Oh, no!
That went dead!
That's a really...
I didn't realize this...
Guys!
I didn't realize.
That's a high tiered nerd.
I don't know guys know this, but like real word names are
actually so difficult to get.
I just saw that it was a side bunny.
I was like, oh, I don't really like that, bro.
I don't really like that color.
No!
The tier list!
the dear list anyway let's go to the neo boards I can't
believe it oh my god I don't read no I don't premium to chat
with the cool people anyway so this was basically where I
used to hang out I would hang out on the roleplaying boards
right here this is where I would hang out I would hang out
there and then I also would hang out I hang out there and
also like the general board but like I'm a little worried
what the general discussion is how do you think Neopets.com
has affected your brain what?
there's definitely some neurons that are going to connect us
after it we're like I learned how to read and type at a
level Lightning speed.
That did not go with me.
Um.
Neopet's brain rot.
Alright.
But yes.
I used to hang out here.
My neopet just got stupider.
What?
Like father like son.
Oh my god.
Yes this is.
Um.
uh this is where i used to uh used to hang out with uh hang
like hang out at here and also the roleplay boards um so
yeah um it was fun it was oh i'll show you the i'll show you
the pounds neopets pounds where is it um and see pet trading
here you go this is a tier list untaking name board world
drake up for trade like there's like so many like uh Up for
auction.
Drake's- I told you, Drake's were like the rarest shit ever.
Everybody was like, I want a Drake.
Seeking feminine names, starting with A.
A few pets up for trade.
Any- seeking- I don't know what- what is four to six.
What the fuck is- S?
Okay, I don't even know some of these.
I don't even know set of some of these names right now.
Like, what does it mean?
Seeking 4 slash 6Ls beginning with what?
Oh, letters.
Oh, yeah.
Some people would like want specific letters as well.
Any three to five letter, female, rare word, real word, real
names starting with A out there.
Like, what?
And her pets.
No, I rejected her.
plastic plastic was worth so much oh my god i can't believe
it i didn't read i can't believe i didn't read the fucking
economy very this is just one guy whoa whoa that was scary
well i'm not moving anymore oh my Oh my god, that was so
scary.
I stopped moving.
Oh my god.
What happened?
I froze.
Can you guys still hear me?
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I broke.
I broke down just then.
I don't.
Oh my god.
Fear.
You guys can hear me.
Okay, that's good to know.
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
Oh, everything crashed.
That's what happened.
Oh, guys.
Yeah.
Wait, I've been doing this for two hours.
Oh, my God.
I love Neopets so much, guys.
Okay, I think that was a good sign.
I think that was a good sign, guys.
I think I didn't think.
Oh, my God.
My OPS.
Guys, my OBS is fucked up.
Guys, I'm gonna restart my OBS, guys.
I can't even swap scenes.
My OBS is fucked up.
All right, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
We're in the void.
I can't.
I can't even swap scenes.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was crazy.
That was mine.
Back.
Okay.
All right.
Before we...
I forgot.
I really wanted to...
to show you guys this the the game section okay some of my
favorite games all right we're so back guys sorry i don't
know what happened my my screen like flashed like it was
just flashed and then everything just stopped working i had
to like close my obs and i had to close my like i had to
close like like a lot of stuff and then and that to reopen
them it was so weird i don't know i don't know what happened
there all right so my favorite games i would tell you guys
what my favorite clicker it's like there's a lot of the
classic games in here so this is like some of my favorite
games that i used to love also like you guys are wondering
why my dokey birds because um um somebody took dokey bird
like on the day i came back
i don't i don't know how they took so then i went i went
that's why i'm not Doki birds.
That's why that's my username.
They grabbed my username on the day I came back.
So that's why.
Luckily, they did not take Doki birds.
So I now I'm birds.
Now I'm plural for them.
But this was my favorite game of all time.
Right there.
Popular.
This was literally this is literally snake.
But like Mirkas.
But I would play It is so much as a as a child like this is
literally one of my new pet new points farm games and like
oh my god This is oh my god.
I'm just looking at this.
This is literally like oh my god.
This is actually memories right now like Okay, why why is
that the edge?
Oh my god like old classic java games fact that they work is
actually, I'm so happy that these guys still work.
Uh, oh my god.
There's a lot of like really no, okay.
I'm not as good as I was.
I used to be really good.
Okay.
I used to be really, really good at this, this game.
Trust me.
I used to be super good at this game, guys.
Oh my god bouncy supreme I remember this Jelly world's not
real by the way Oh my god Oh my god Jelly world Oh my god
This game Oh
This used to be like a classic flash No!
I used to be really good at this game too see oh my god okay
okay whatever
it's like actually oh my god a classic that's such a classic
oh my god i'm sorry i'm going through like memory nostalgia
lane at the moment um popularity a lot of the popular games
are like people that like had so much happy memories like
play and stuff oh my god ice cream machine ice cream machine
guys i also used to be really good at this game oh so like
basically it's just avoid the ice cream this was a really
fun game to farm like meal points and stuff so um they used
to have like so many crossovers too oh shit sorry i was
looking at the screen i was looking guys i wasn't bad i was
looking at chat you saw my my eyes dart to the right i was i
was literally my god oh yeah by the way there's poker so
like you know wait is that actual poker wait does it i know
torus we all know pirates in the world you guys strangle oh
okay no never mind there's actual card games i remember
wasn't it card games yeah there you go cheat there you go so
here You learned how to play cards You learned You learned
Um I don't remember how to play this game Sure Uh and then
you have to like Cheat about like what cards You have Oh
they have black Wait they do have poker Alright I'm just
gonna cheat right now I have three Yay no one accused me of
cheating Alright Alright Played two eights.
Oh, wait, you guys don't see this.
I'm going to accuse her of cheating.
Yes, I caught it cheating!
Oh, yeah, and then you win Neopoints for catching the
cheater.
Oh, yeah, and then it was like Solitaire and everything.
Wait, so like if you guys don't know how to play, if you
guys don't know how to play card games, you can go to
Neopets and play it legally.
Let's see.
Where is Poker?
Was there actually Poker?
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize there were actually Poker.
I just knew there were card games.
I didn't even realize there was actually...
Yeah, it was basically bullshit.
Oh, yeah, they have slots, too.
Wait, isn't that in the pure historic?
Where was the slots machine?
I know, like, some of you guys who've never played Neopets
before are, like, you can't be...
Like, are you actually seeing real...
No, there was!
There was actual slot machines!
There was, like, slot machines here.
Uh...
Where was it?
Anyway, where was the slot machines again, guys?
Uh, yeah, it was a desert.
Oh, it was.
It was a desert.
I remember now.
All right, anyway, there's poker here somewhere.
I just don't remember where it was.
I just don't know.
Poker was here somewhere.
Okay, let's see.
Uh, where was it?
Okay, explore.
We gotta go to the desert.
Lost desert.
Oh, my chat's frozen.
Okay, I'll fix it.
I'll fix you guys.
Don't worry.
Doki, you can fix you.
I can fix you.
Give me a sec.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
All right, so I think it is here.
The food stall, there's Solitaire.
There's the fruit machine.
There you go.
All right.
Oh, and there's a scratch card.
Yeah.
Okay, so you go to fruit machine.
machine and then you spin you can spin you can spin this so
it's like slots
yay did I win anything okay no sorry this is oh yeah but
they like limit so like you know they don't they make sure
to limit you like uh one spin a day because you know they
don't want to oh I want to do scratch cards oh my god and
they would have scratch cards too so uh wait Oh, wait,
that's a jackpot.
Fuck, okay.
No!
Okay, we got...
I can't do the scratch cards yet.
Poker's Miradel?
Okay, we're going to go to Miradel.
We're going to go to Miradel.
Miradel is...
Oh, that's Brightvale.
Do I go to Miradel?
Where's Poker?
By the way, this is the turtle racing.
So this is where the horse...
The betting...
just are so so um so here is like we can see like um uh um
you can make three bets a day and then we can bet on the
turtles which is like the horses so you can be like who do
you want to and you can feed them enhanced items and
So, technically, there's horse racing, too.
Let's go gambling.
Oh, there it is, poker!
I don't know how to play poker, but I'm going to join
because I have the money.
I have two... I'm rich.
Alright, how do you click the deal button to start the
tournament?
Okay.
I'm ready to start.
Guys, it's not cheating if I have all of chat to help me do
poker.
Each player is your turn to start.
You got a hand...
Check, bet, or fold, guys.
Guys, do I check, bet, or fold?
I've never played poker before.
I don't know how I'll play poker.
Guys, I don't.
I don't know.
Check?
Okay, we're going to check.
You checked.
What happened?
What did I check?
I... Okay, continue.
All right.
He also checked.
Continue.
all right he also checked continue all right we're all
checking all right oh Nigel bet 10 neopoints it's my turn do
I all in raise I can't do all in I can only raise I'll raise
all right I raised it to 20 neopoints that's like 20 cents
oh they also bet 20 everybody's betting Are we doing good?
First round, Ben complete.
It's your turn to discard.
Click the card to discard.
Wait, what do I discard?
Guys, what card do I discard?
I've never played poker before.
What card?
The two?
This one?
All right, discard.
Nice.
I got a five.
I got a five D.
All right.
Wait, you can describe more than one?
Oh, I was supposed to describe the other five?
Oh, a pair.
Okay, we got a pair.
We're doing it.
Okay.
All right.
Check, bet, or fold.
Uh.
Check.
All right.
Checking time.
We continue.
Oh, my God, guys.
Guys, we're doing so well.
Oh, my God.
they call 20 nil points.
Oh, they fold it.
Ha!
What a loser.
I can't believe.
Oh, it's your turn to move.
Call or raise.
Call?
Call.
Okay.
I called it.
But second round is bed incomplete.
Show to see who wins the 230 plop.
Do I... Did I win?
Guys, I lost.
Guys, I thought you guys were good at this.
Guys, I had so many people here to help me gamble.
Like, what happened?
What's this music?
That's the music of my defeat.
That's what it is.
Wait, no, I don't want to do this again.
My community sucks at poker.
Wait, I don't know what I'm doing And they don't know how to
play poker
Yo, wait, this hand was fire Wait, that hand was good Oh no
No, I didn't flush Oh my god You only stop when you're just
about to hit the jackpot and you always deserve it i can't
believe it i can't no i'm so sad it's time to spin the wheel
yay i just won back the money i lost
I cannot fail.
I literally won more money after leaving the table.
Let's go.
Wild, wild, wild luck.
Never punished.
I heard like Meal Pets has like a new TGC now too.
uh or tcg sorry tcg trading card game they also just
announced a new trading card game which is really
interesting too um i'm literally unable oh yeah kiko lake
i'll show you how ugly the kikos are look at this they live
in such an ugly house look at this they're so like
narcissistic their houses are just shaped like them they're
so look at how ugly this is Who would want to live here?
Who wouldn't so mean?
Rune.
They're like the only, they're like the only town, the only
town that has like houses that's just their faces.
Nobody else has that.
It's only them.
Stop being such an anti.
Never!
I even if the Kikos gave everybody $5 billion I will still
be the last hater alive I'll be the last Kiko hater alive
and jump jump too don't forget the jump jumps um that felt
really the Kikos alone
Yeah, Kiko Lake has the worst Altador team.
They have the worst Altador team in everything.
Oh yeah, you can visit Santa.
Do you guys want to visit Santa in Neopetsland?
Wait, where's Santa?
Santa used to live here.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did Santa go?
Santa used to live here.
What happened to Santa?
Santa used to Yeah, there was Santa in New Pinsland It's
July Santa's eternal Don't say that Santa's eternal He's
here forever Anyway, this is like The Christmas town In In
In And a lot of Neopets He's real in Neopets, you don't
understand He's real in Neopets
Alright, but I want to go?
Fuck, I don't remember why I wanted to go Where I wanted to
show you guys Oh yeah, Altador Here you go, this is Altador
This was like the So the Altador Cup is gonna show up soon
Or is it Altadour.
Oh, the legendary pet pets.
Is there still any pet pets?
No.
God damn it.
Alright.
People will buy anything.
Alright, let's see.
The Altadour Cup.
There you go.
So you can see, like, these are, like, the teams and stuff.
I am a full-on.
I'm a full-on.
Oh, wait.
You can't even see.
You can't see the teams yet.
But, yeah, basically, like, to represent your team, you get,
like, free stuff, too, from here.
The Altadour Cup is so fun to play.
I remember grinding Altadour Cup so much um as a child
because like um um if points matter uh so like uh you have
to like play for your team look at kiko like look at this
guy your team's gonna fucking lose nobody likes you
i'll be your auntie forever kiko lay
my mind stop it's like it's like soccer there's always you
know you know like in soccer there's always fans that hate a
certain team i'm that fat hot and woods for life
hot and woods for life
The Rue Island.
I mean, Rue Island is fun.
Rue Island is really...
Rue Island is Australia.
It's basically Australia.
So, like, they're an island filled with these, like,
bloomeroos.
That's what they're called.
So, uh, they are basically...
And they're ruled by a king called King Rue.
Uh, so...
They...
Um...
Oh, yeah.
Kiko Lake?
Was...
Was Kiko Lake...
known to always be last place was that it uh was that it
they've always kiko lake has been last place for years i
don't know i don't know who who who decided to help them
yeah they never escaped the monarchy sad well to be fair a
lot of them are the monarchy wait what's this?
What team is this?
What the?
Who let this team in?
After finally accepting the invitation to compete in the
Altadur Cup, Dicardia, who are you guys?
They discovered a new place?
Who?
Oh, they're new!
Oh!
I'm like, who are you guys?
guys i've never seen dark i've never seen this this map
before um it's the app team that promotes an oh oh it's a
mobile game wait they haven't introduced the others yet like
how like oh there's like you see like who wait they're all
just like striped they're all striped and everything oh
there's some teams that haven't been reintroduced yet um i
was team haunted woods and darren oh my God, you guys are so
badass.
Show us the Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub-Jub have
no representation.
Because they don't...
I'm gonna stop.
I don't know.
They're in somebody's team.
I don't remember which team they're in.
I actually don't know which team they're in.
They're not captain.
All these show the...
All these show the other teams.
But like, like, even...
At least Kiko Lake has their own town.
Oh, Miradel has...
Yeah, Miradel...
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Miradel has the Jub-Jub.
Yeah, I think the Jub-Jub was like...
I don't remember.
But yeah, there they...
Wait, they kicked him.
Oh, there he is.
Look at him.
He's so talented.
Honey, what is he gonna do?
The altar there cup is for people with hands.
What are you gonna do?
You can't kick a bot?
You need a run!
That's the bot.
He is the bot.
He's best.
Don't disrespect this guy's feet.
Oh, he is the paw.
Keep moving.
This is Drake neighborhood.
Oh, my God.
All I'm saying.
Boss, when he's the goalkeeper, you don't even have hands.
What the heck?
I like how he's the goalkeeper.
goalkeeper um he's a goalkeeper but like you know it's about
like catching the ball and
oh my god um uh anyway i just don't like jub-jubs i just i
just personally don't like jub-jubs i just don't like i just
don't think like he's cute
He's the...
Alright.
Is it play?
He can...
Jump jump is my Oshi.
Um...
I'm your Oshi's auntie.
I'm a jump jump auntie.
Anyway.
It's funny.
I think like Kiko Lake is like...
I don't think I think Kiko Lake is really funny because like
you can see that like it's three Kikos and then like who why
is there horses like I thought I I think it's like really
funny because it's like it's all Kikos and then two horses
like the uni and then the um I forgot the other one the
other horse the fish horse and the land horse um I don't
remember the fish horse's um the seahorses yeah no but they
have a name they have a name i don't remember what they're
called the pio fins oh the pio fins sorry i never gave pio
fins much attention because i it wasn't like my favorite
neal pet um but yeah i just thought it was really funny
because it's like kiko lake but like two of them are like
not kikos
um they do that a lot they apparently did like team
transfers too where like they transferred people because
it's like soccer it's like it's like soccer where it's like
they have like team like teammates transfer to like a
different uh a different like team and everything like so
they're not like from that place but yeah this is i love the
alterator cup people get like so passionate about alter
It's just like the real, it's like real sports.
People get, oh my God, I remember during the first year of
the Altadour Cup, during the first year of the Altadour Cup,
people got so passionate.
There was like actual shit talking on the boards and
everything because people were like really passionate about
like the teams in the Altadour Cup.
So they started like, they started seeing mad shit on the
boards.
Like they'll be like, wait, can we see it?
I wonder if people are still passionate about it.
Oh my, I'm actually so curious.
Are people still, like, super passionate about the AltruDirt
Cup?
Is the AltruDirt Cup?
Does the AltruDirt Cup have a board yet?
No!
We can't experience it!
Wait, current site events, general discussion.
Oh, I wish we could see it.
It's actually really funny.
Oh, there you go.
Dom, please address the 2022 AltruDirt Cup results.
it what about
the results oh my god people are so passionate i told you
guys before we oh whoa oh my god oh there you go this is it
don't stop believing official haunted woods z-booties Woo!
Haunted Woods!
Let's go!
I'm definitely back!
I'm definitely backing Haunted Woods this year!
Let's go!
Oh my god, people even have like their fucking...
Oh my god!
have like they're like repping oh my god like they're
repping oh my god for now haunted woods the signatures oh my
god they added the wood haunted woods i got oh my god it
went to sick gotta wrap it we gotta wrap the oh this is good
this is a good signature oh my god
before this was me, this was me as a child.
Oh my god, I forgot about that.
That's what I mean, people were so passionate.
And then there's like, um, here before the gray and here
after.
Roll agains, y'all rule of the day.
Oh my god, roll again, roll again, are here too.
The roll again.
22 oh no anyone doing so forfeits the code for complete list
of rules visit rule again okay let me i need to see this
website this is like a i need to see oh my god oh my god oh
my god they created a whole website dedicated to the rule
again welcome to the Ruligans!
Oh, my God!
Respect recruiting!
Oh!
We're doing true!
The dedication!
Oh, my God!
Ruligans!
Veterans!
These users have been ruligans for many years.
Oh, my God!
actually this was all created on neopets by the way oh man
you guys this is all created like it's a legit website on
neopets that somebody coded like they coded this all by
themselves on neopets because you can make like neopet you
can customize your own website and everything on neopets too
and oh my god i've told you guys people get so passionate
about the alchidder co Oh, you need to log in.
Don't worry.
Use my referral code.
Use my...
Guys, you can use my referral code if you want to log in.
If you want to see it.
Oh, my God.
I told you guys.
People look.
Oh, my God.
Look at their signature.
The rule again board is popping.
Oh, my God.
The signature is so cool.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Anyway, guys.
I think showcasing you guys the Altar to our cup is a good
way to call it here.
It's a good way to call it here.
Oh my god.
That was great.
Oh, I'm so happy.
I'm really happy.
Also, guys, you guys have my new background?
Did you guys...
Did you guys like my new background?
It's animated now You guys can move Yeah They move now Um
But like I said a huge Huge huge huge shout out Uh to Neal
Pets Uh for sponsoring me I'm so happy to be able to like Uh
look through the website for you guys I hope a lot of you
guys sign up Join in go back to Neal Pets Explore a little
bit Explore the community Explore the website There's a lot
of updates coming in for Neopets.
And feel free to use my referral code to create an account.
I hope you guys would enjoy it a lot about the experience
and everything.
And also make sure to check out the new plot of The Void
Within, guys.
Because that was the whole point.
I hope you guys check out the void within and um Wait, I
never showed a new content.
I did.
Didn't I not?
I looked at the void within there?
I what?
No, I did.
I looked at the void within.
Did they just update it again?
Like did they?
I did it?
Wait, what did I miss?
What did I miss?
What did I miss in the void within?
Okay, we're going back, guys.
Sponsor is still going in.
Okay.
I thought I did.
What else did I miss?
There was a surprise update?
What happened?
Guys, round three.
Apparently something happened.
Sorry, we're back.
We're back to the void within.
Oh, it's just because I didn't collect all the essence.
You have to collect essence, by the way.
the way um so there's like you can see like some of the
stories like what's happening so that you get to explore but
i did i looked at the story and everything and then there's
the boards of people talking about it do you want me to send
you guys to battle i'll do it oh
do you guys really want me to send you okay i'm gonna send
you guys to battle you guys wanted a battle you guys wanted
it i said i said i don't know if you guys can handle the
battle all right so we're gonna go with advance and then
we're gonna fight these challengers we're gonna fight these
guys right here and then i'm ready uh we're sending you in
because you guys requested it So I'm going to send...
Can I plus this?
Oh, my neopets is...
You're too sick?
I can't believe it!
You guys didn't have to fight because you're too sick!
No!
We'll send the rabbit in.
We're going to send the rabbit in.
Alright.
Wait, where's the void within?
Where did it come from?
go oh shit i fucked it up i fucked it up boy there it is all
right
no i want to send you guys in i'm so sad i can't believe it
they won't let me send you in guys i don't understand i wish
that why not
fight all right find my next move oh my god this is new i do
this oh it's like rock paper scissors oh wait no i just it's
just rock i can only punch it oh i'm so dead we're i'm so
holy shit oh guys it was one hit
oops all right guys i don't think i should have selected um
i don't think i should have selected advanced guys i don't i
i can't believe it why were you guys sick can't be me oh no
no did i got you guys no it can't be me guys it can't why
did you pick events because i thought i was gonna send the
dragoons in i was gonna teach them a lesson They wanted to
be on the battlefield I was trying to teach them a lesson
And then I ended up Accidentally sending a I had to send in
a different Neopet in
I was just trying to teach you guys a lesson
Fix you guys I'm too poor I don't have enough money To feel
Guys I don't have enough money to to buy medicine.
I can't even go to the soup kitchen.
She's just gonna kick us out.
I don't know why she thinks I'm too rich to go to the soup
kitchen.
It's so unfair.
Look.
Every time you have only really poor Neal pets can get hand
oh wait she's only really poor neopess can get handouts at
the soup kitchen
sorry i'm sorry guys i can't i can't feed you guys oh yeah
forgot to show you guys there's a hotel too um let's see
neopia bazaar So there's like, where's the hotel?
There used to be hotels here.
Oh, yes, the Neal Lodge.
So you can place your, um, so you can place your favorite
Neal pets to like, um, to like, uh, the, the hotel.
And then like, so they can get, like, pampered and
everything.
But like, I don't, I can't afford it.
So, oh yeah, there's like, um, uh, one of them is called
Cockroach Towers.
And it's, they just want to be in a hotel.
tell guys you guys want to
i can take you guys to cockroach towers all right there's
there's there's like astro villa but 500 is a little bit too
much so we're gonna go with five meal points and we're gonna
give you a day there you go yes so there's like one to two
stars there's oh wait does it show you like example rooms oh
my god i'm so funny It actually shows you guys like what the
hotel rooms look like
Alright, alright guys, you're lucky Guys, you're lucky I won
the, I won the spinning wheel thing I got $2,500 so I can
book you one night in cockroach towers Fine, fine, I'll get
you the flea pit motel I feel a little generous right now I
like how one of them is called cheap hotel um guys i feel
extra generous today so i'm gonna put you at the flea pit
motel i'll book you guys in there you go your hotel bill is
as follows this will be deducted 10 cost of extra cost per
night 10 meal points oh my god i broke the bank for you oh
my god we're gonna have to like we're gonna have to like um
cut on some of our expenses dragon but i hope you enjoyed
the hotel i hope you
i hope you enjoy it we might not be able to have dinner
tomorrow but um but it'll be worth it you have two million
points all right all right yeah we sent you to the hotel all
right all right i think we're good yeah that was fun um that
was a lot of fun um i really really did um i really did
enjoy showcasing you guys um all the neopet stuff and uh and
i really enjoyed um just like you know going through like
nostalgia and everything i hit the The rule again.
I talked about the void.
What do you mean?
And the reason why I went more so of like, I wanted to be
more beginner friendly too.
Because I feel like the void within, you definitely need to
know a lot more about like Neopets in general.
more about what's going on Neopets because a lot of you guys
might be looking into Neopets or coming back to Neopets
after years and years and years.
So I wanted to make it more beginner-friendly for you guys
and like just like just go through like the introduction of
everything like introducing bits and parts of Neopets just
to build up.
The void within the plot line definitely you need to have
more you have to explore the rest of Neopets.
The rest of Neopets a lot more and I really highly suggest
checking out the old plots as well the old comics and
everything because there's so much lore into it there's so
much that went into building up to this main plot that
they're doing right now um and they've worked incredibly oh
sorry the double bgm sorry they worked so hard in setting
this up they haven't they haven't done plots in a long time
so this is like their um they're big one of their biggest
ones in a very very long time huge shout out again for
neopets for for the sponsor i'm so happy i can't believe i
got i got like paid to like talk about neopets that's i'm
really really happy but um i hope you guys give a lot of
support uh to neopets and follow them um in their socials i
gave a link to each of their socials in the description um
join campaign 150k neocash is a lot of real money it's
basically real money um in neopets where you can like buy
more like uh cosmetics and like unlock some premium features
in neopets so i highly suggest joining the campaign if you
want to invest more into it and want to see if you're lucky
enough to get the win the campaign um and uh use my referral
link if you want to uh check neopets is definitely um it's
definitely uh for those who like to just like do something
like just like have something to do like you have some free
time and just want to play something it does neopets does
have like a good uh way to pass the time and there is a lot
of lore and a lot of like games and like um uh features in
there and i'm really excited because like they're planning
on adding more and more and more updates um to neopets and
like the company is like super passionate about neopets and
um wanting to revitalize the community again so i hope you
guys check it out oh my god it was so fun i had so much fun
though it really was i'm really happy to finally be able to
play the game and like share it with you guys
thank you everybody again let's uh thank neopets again um
thank neopets again i'll make a tweet after about more of
the details but please check out the void within um if you
want to come back to neo pets check out the new plot line
for those who are like veteran neo pets players and want to
know what the new plot was and like explore more into it i
always suggest checking out the void within and everything
but thank you everybody as always everyone buddy stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys Bye!